i think the dna revolution hasn't quite
sunk in like this isn't like a lot of
medical things you know if you've ever
noticed you hear of a discovery and they
say in 10 years this is going to be big
that means they have no idea if it's
going to happen if they say five years
it means maybe it'll happen but the
point about this is it's happening now
and this is really transformational
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people it does not get any more
fascinating than the brilliant guest we
have for you today he is a geneticist
and the author of blueprint how dna
makes us who we are professor robert
plum and welcome to trigonometry thank
you very much i'm really pleased to be
here oh we are so grateful to have you
here we can't wait for the conversation
we're going to have before we do though
tell everybody a little bit about your
story through life you've you've written
this great book of course you're one of
the most cited people in your field in
the world uh you've done incredible
studies with twins tell us about your
your life your academic career the
history of how you are here talking to
us
well that that can take us a few hours
give you the two-minute version of it
you know i've been doing research in
this area for 50 years and when i
started back in 1970
in psychology you couldn't really talk
about genetics given nazi germany and
the fact that psychology was completely
environmentalistic the idea that
everything we are
is what we learned what our mothers did
to us in the first few years of life
and so it's been very rewarding for me
to see over the 40 years as data piled
up and convinced most reasonable
scientists and i think society as a
whole that genetics is important you
know i haven't been called a nazi for 30
years probably
but you know back when i started it was
really dangerous professionally and
politically to even talk about genetics
so that's been really rewarding to see
and that's why i wrote this book a few
years ago because after 50 years of
research in this field where i was kind
of keeping my head down i'm kind of
embarrassed to say because i wanted to
do the research i didn't want to get
distracted so i didn't respond to people
who attacked me you know because i
thought in the end if psychology is
going to be a science it'll be convinced
by data so keep your nose down collect
the data and that really did happen you
know so much data piled up that any
reasonable person looking at this amount
of data from adoption studies twin
studies now dna studies you just can't
ignore the importance of genetic
differences between people so that's
what my book is called blueprint how dna
makes us who we are and there's a lot to
say about that you know
you sort of have to start in media res
you know where
there's so much background you have to
try to fill in because nature nurture
makes us who we are not as humans we're
talking about why we differ between each
other and we've got three billion base
pairs of dna that we inherit from our
parents
we're only talking about the one percent
that differs between us because that's
what makes us different so there's so
many things like that to talk about and
maybe we'll get into that as the
conversation goes along but is that
enough oh absolutely
well
we will get to that right away but
actually just very quickly you mentioned
you know not being called bad you know
terrible things for for a while
what has you know you've been in act in
that sphere for 50 years what how have
you observed some of the sort of ebbs
and flows of the ability to freedom of
research and freedom of expression and
that sort of thing in academia yeah well
i'm puzzled by the current um
culture of academia i don't know where
that came from because i was always
interested in science because you can
explore anything and as long as it's
empirical and there's issues like
religious issues that you know you
really can't
tackle empirically but i want to study
things that are tractable empirically
and then you have your view i have mine
that's fun let's do research
and figure out which
who's right
you know so that's the sort of stuff i'd
like to do
and so it's been um appalling for me to
well when i was in the states there was
a rise in the religious right and you
couldn't talk about god issues not a big
deal but i felt it was less
open and
that bothered me a lot because you know
university should be anything they
should be a place where you can talk
about anything you know in as adults you
know which is what i like about this
podcast so much i like to see you two
guys disagree with each other and show
people you know you can disagree about
some pretty profound things
and you know still be friends and
and actually enjoy the discussion
so i in in the early 90s i had an
opportunity to come to the uk and my
wife at that time was um british and
tried living in the states and didn't
like it and i had this view from my time
we spent most of our summers in britain
and i got to you know she was from
cambridge and so i got to know quite a
few people and i had the feeling that
things were more open
in the uk
and
i i've now come to realize that's only
because americans are not subtle
you know and that it's more chinese
whisper stuff yeah yeah whereas in
america it's bright in your face you
know if
people coming up and disagreeing with
you
so i don't think it's as open as i
thought it was
but um i'm at a place at the institute
of psychiatry with some of the brightest
people i know and there you really can
talk about anything
so
uh i uh so from a genetics point of view
i went from not being able to talk about
genetics to now being asked to give
talks to public groups and lots of
people about genetics so everyone seems
to be interested in genetics and i don't
know if i'm polyanish about it but i
think it's partly because the data has
just built up i could have wasted my
time i think trying to argue with people
but as a scientist i thought no it's
better just take a long view of it
and
collect the data and hope that it stays
in empirical science we're in the end
data rules you know and
and so i think that's kind of spread
into society the other thing that's come
along that's been huge in the last 20
years is the dna revolution
because you can argue about twin studies
adoption studies
you can't argue with dna when you show
that this bit of inherited dna relates
to that trait
it's kind of what can you say really you
know so for a lot for all those reasons
i think science has certainly become
not just accepting but in you know
really enthusiastic about genetics it's
one of the hottest areas
in in the life sciences now but i also
think in um in society as a whole you
know when my book came out i was really
worried about the reception
and
when i gave these public lectures
you know people were very keen on it i
didn't get any flack you know whereas
people thought i was going to get
clobbered when i went to these talks
well some of your friends said it's a
suicide note yeah yeah and i really
didn't know how it was going to come out
you know because i've spent i've never
been so open about it you know after 50
years i decided you know my age what
have i got to lose
tell it like it is you know tell it as i
see it which i think is the way it is
and so i was really pleased that
the public reception was very good the
flack i got was more from
academics and my work is on cognitive
development so it touches on education
and education is still the backwater of
of
really anti-genetics still it's like
psychology 30 40 years ago
where there's just a knee-jerk reaction
against genetics somehow thinking
that if genetics is important then
features are useless you know i mean
where if they
knew anything about this they realized
that's not at all true clinicians used
to think that in psychology it's going
to genetics is going to put them out of
business but it puts them in business in
a way i mean if you can say well this
disorder is different from that disorder
and maybe people who have a strong
genetic propensity for
vulnerability might respond to
treatments differently
maybe drug treatments or cognitive
behavioral therapy so
i think education will go that way
eventually but boy it's it's um slow
going and that's where i got the
hostility more than any other area not
from teachers so much though more from
the academics do you know
so it's i know that's a very long-winded
way of saying i don't really know
but it's so interesting you bring up
education robert because
and everyone will drink now but as a
former teacher oh right
so
i remember talking to one of my uh head
of department or ahead of years i can't
remember what it was of the deputy head
and they went to me francis why is it
that this cohort hasn't done as well as
your previous cohort your previous
cohort did really well but this goal not
as well why do you think that is and i
went well they're just not as smart
and he just looked at me absolutely
horrified you can't say that but
we all have
different capabilities so and that is
genetics isn't it really yeah yeah i
think when you talk to teachers not to
higher level people or academics in
education you can't teach 30 kids in a
classroom and not notice that some kids
learn
you guys got to stay out of their way
and they're going to learn lots of stuff
whereas other kids you know need a lot
more help to just get up to minimum
levels of literacy and numeracy and so i
i think we did a survey of teachers and
how they feel about genetics and
although they get no genetics in their
training they don't even know about
genetics other than a few
very rare single gene mutations which
they'll never see
you know that they don't get anything
about genetics yet they're quite um
a response
they accept the idea of genetic
differences and they don't know much
about it but in general they're willing
to say you know as you're suggesting
that kids do differ
and
to assume that those differences are
only due to the teachers or if you can't
blame the teachers you blame the parents
if you can't blame the parents you blame
the kids they're lazy or whatever but
you know it's so important to recognize
and respect the fact that people differ
and they differ genetically
and
that doesn't mean you give up to the
contrary you know it depends on your
views but it could mean you say well we
need to put this called the finish model
in education put all the resources
needed to get everybody up to some
minimal levels of literacy and numeracy
so that they can participate in society
and you know
galton who founded francis galton who's
also a bad name right now because of
eugenics but
he started this field of genetics of
human behavior and especially cognitive
development and he said
ability will out meaning
you don't have to do much you kind of
have to stay out of the way of if you
seem like musically gifted kids or
mathematically gifted kids they don't
need the best teachers in the world you
know they're just going to
pick it up themselves and with the
internet now you know there's no
stopping
these kids so i think the teacher's
perspective on this is really good
because the problem problem with parents
is they only see a couple kids one in
your case three kids is it no i've just
got the one all right just born in a few
weeks ago that's right i haven't seen
much personality yet i see
but i take your point i take your point
as a parent you only see your kids yeah
yeah and
you know kids are different from adults
and you know so if you ask them about
their kid they oh very active well
actually no this kid's kind of a
vegetable
whereas if you're a teacher
and you see all these kids and you say
this kid is really hyperactive you can
believe it but the thing i always found
interesting looking with kids is that
you'd get kids from the same family yeah
they're completely different exactly and
genetically you go well they can't have
the same father they have the same
mother yeah one kid is super bright and
you know you don't know that no that
that is true that is
true you know father anyway yeah same
mother
and you have so you see one kid who's
super bright and then the other one who
comes along and it isn't as bright and
in many ways we do those kids a
disservice because then we compare them
to the brother and the sister and they
go why are you like them exactly right
well there's a great saying that parents
are environmentalists
until they have more than one kid
so i know you're not an environmentalist
you don't think everything comes from
what the parents do to the kids or that
sort of thing
but um most parents you know you can
attract the problem with environmental
theories you can explain anything so if
you're is it a daughter uh son
is uh shy say or something you can
always explain you can say oh you didn't
take him out enough when he was young or
whatever but then you have a second
child and they're so different as you're
saying francis
but genetics predicts that kids are
different because they're 50 similar
genetically but that means they're 50
percent different genetically and so
when you have more than one child you
really see it because shyness is one of
the most heritable characteristics in
infancy
and if given that if you have one child
who's very shy chances are the other one
will be less shy and you know you see
these differences in personality and i
didn't do that and so
that's why they say
parents are environmentalists generally
until they have more than one child
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
so let's get into the core of your work
because it's absolutely fascinating so
interesting in terms of understanding
how we differ and why we differ and who
we are you talked about how teachers may
not be taught genetics
what should they be taught what should
we all be taught about genetics at a
base level as a society so that we
understand ourselves and our friends and
partners and other people strangers
better and ourselves yeah that um
inherited dna differences
are
the major systematic force making us who
we are as individuals
and that has a lot of ramifications but
one part of it that's really important
is we have less control over our
children say
than we think we do
not just because of the genetics but
genetic research has shown the
environment works very differently from
the way we thought it worked the
environmentalism was dominated by the
idea of nurture
that the way kids develop is the way
their parents treat them a lot of it was
mother blaming if a kid becomes
schizophrenic you don't find out until
they're 20 or so and then you're told
it's because what you did
of what you did in the first few years
of life which is as wicked as it can be
right because you did it but you can't
change can't go back
17 years and do it differently and it
was wrong you know there's no evidence
that that's what it's about the
environmental influences are important
they account for the other half of the
differences between us in all traits
psychopathology cognitive abilities
personality all these traits are about
50
we say heritable that is
where the differences are caused by
inherited dna differences the other half
is environmental but it's not due to
these systematic family effects whatever
it is it's making two kids in the same
family as different from each other as
kids in different families even though
as you say they have the same parents
that's that's probably what it's about
you know that the parents they might be
treating the kids differently but it's
more likely it's uh idiosyncratics you
know stochastic
sorts of factors chance
basically
so that's a double whammy for parents
because first you don't have as much
influence as you think you do because
genetics is the major systematic force
and the environmental side you don't
have the levers to pull either because
it's mostly chance
and so this is a great talk for a new
parent isn't it there's nothing you can
do
i was going to make that joke but it
seemed insensitive
no but that's a you know that is the
point so does that mean as a parent you
just give up and say i can't do anything
right but to the contrary you know it
just means if
i'm sure you're not you don't think this
but there's a lot of parents especially
you know yuppie parents who you know
wait until they're in their 30s or
whatever and then they have their
precious kid
and they're so concerned about making
one false move that's going to screw the
kid up for life
and and the other thing i see is
that
a lot of people still
they know it's wrong but deep down they
still think the kid's a blob of clay
that they're going to mold to be what
they want it to be
and and that doesn't work because you
don't do that far better is to say
like like with your spouse or your
friends
you don't do nice things for them
because you want to make them into
something you want them to be you do it
because you like them
and i think it's really important it
sounds cheesy but it's important for
parents to lighten up and to say you
don't have as much control as you think
but what that means is
you do things for the kid because you
want to make them happy you want life to
be nice for them you're not trying to
make them into what you want them to be
and you know imagine if you did that to
your spouse you say well this person's
not too bad and i can shape shape her up
to be the way i want her to be you know
and that's a disaster right
you do nice things for people you love
because you love them and you want life
to be nice for them so that doesn't mean
you know you let your kid do whatever
they want to do you say no if we go to a
friend's house and you act like an ass
you know it's not going to be nice and
it's going to make all of us kind of
unpleasant and why do that you know so i
think
the relationship is probably more
important it's the longest relationship
we have in life with our children
and
the idea that you're going to mold your
kid is really counterproductive to that
relationship in a way far better to give
the kid opportunities to find out what
they like to do and then help them do
what they like to do because
i think increasingly i don't think it's
aptitudes as much as appetites do you
know i mean they go together sort of but
what determines what people do in life
is more a matter of i don't know i just
do it because i like it sort of and that
what you like to do you do it more and
you do it better and you get better at
it the aptitude almost follows from the
appetite i don't know about you guys but
when i ask friends what is it um why are
you doing what you're doing
and when you get done people can tell
you a story about it
but
very often it's chance sort of stuff and
sort of like i don't know i just kind of
like doing it like i can't imagine
liking to do comedy i mean that would be
my worst nightmare
having to go up on a stage and try and
tell a joke
i can't i can never tell a joke i never
remember a joke i lose the punchline i'm
just not really i guess
interested
you know i love comedy right but i mean
i'm just not interested in producing
comedy like i'm not interested in
producing high level music as well but i
love music i listen to music all the
time it's that sort of thing right
it's so interesting what we're talking
about and this is a question that i want
really wanted to ask you because the
more i read about your work the more i
researched it the more the more i
thought
is free willing an illusion
are we just completely determined by our
genetics i like to think i've got free
will
but you just go a lot of the stuff i've
done is that just my genes
well listen the free will issue is a a
very big
issue um philosophically but say just
and you know like sam harris and people
are saying no such thing as free will
it's all determined but
um
this is a rabbit hole in a way i mean
it's it there's a lot of interesting
stuff there but from a simple genetic
point of view i would say
it's almost the opposite like
now that we have with the dna revolution
we have these
polygenic scores so i can predict
genetic risk from birth so i in my book
i present the world's first profile of
these genetic risk scores for things
like obesity for example or
schizophrenia
and my highest risk score was for
obesity
and so
people might be surprised to learn that
um body weight obesity is nothing more
than high body weight it isn't like a
disease or a disorder it's a perfectly
continuous distribution
so um
by having a high
well first people might be surprised to
learn how heritable individual
differences in weight are when we've
done surveys people think height highly
heritable weight nah it's just free will
people who have problems with their
weight you know they just need to get a
grip pull up their socks you know
you know but um it turns out it's about
60 heritable meaning the differences
between people and their body weight are
60 of the differences are due to
inherited dna differences so where this
comes back to your question is
i have this high like i'm at the 94th
percentile of this genetic risk but i'm
at the only 70th percentile of actual
body weight
you know that still gives me a bmi near
on the cusp of
obesity really but you're doing quite
well given your genetic inheritance well
that's it and instead of me giving up
and saying i'm destined to be a genetic
fatty i can't do anything about it i
find for that and for many other genetic
risks like heart disease or whatever
it actually motivates you
to do better so i know that my weight
isn't a matter of you know the
every year it's it's invidious you know
i put a few year a few pounds on every
year but the problems they don't go away
and so by recognizing i'm in this kind
of battle of the bulge
it's it's a lifelong battle and so what
i do is i arrange my environment i just
can't have junk food in the house you
know with the best of intentions you
come home late one night and these those
crisps start talking to you you know oh
just one crisp you know and then the
whole bag's gone and you know you could
say
i could i could have the self-control
but you know
life you kind of you live it on the fly
and things happen and sometimes
you
you you lose that and other people
wouldn't have that sort of uh those
those crips they could leave on on the
shelf you know i just can't have them in
the house so i've learned that i can't
have biscuits in the house and stuff
like that and i still have to struggle
with it but um it helps me to know i've
got this genetic propensity
for putting on weight so i think weight
is a good example of of what you're
talking about just because it's
heritable doesn't mean there's nothing
you can do about it and there no trait
is 100 heritable
um
body weight
is you know at the higher level 60
percent most traits are about 50
heritable personality about 40 so
there's still a lot of non-genetic
influence but
as i said those influences
are largely chance and idiosyncratic
but you can take advantage of those
probably and say you know i'm gonna
work hard to keep my weight down i could
definitely
work harder at it but you know i'm only
willing to give that so much energy in
my life plus i love food you know and
so um that's a strong yesterday yeah
that is yeah um so we've been talking
about the inheritability of obesity and
as a man who struggled with his weight
thank you for telling me it's not my
fault
i really appreciate it we're gonna have
to up the fat shaving mate
but what about addiction
um well
one thing one comment one rule sort of
is after 50 years of research is
everything's heritable
but nothing's 100 heritable so the the
work on addiction um suggests it's
moderately heritable you know in general
about 40 percent heritable
and people are trying to get
genetic predict dna predictors we call
them polygenic scores because these
aren't these genetic influences aren't
due to a handful they're not due to one
gene or a handful gene they're due to
thousands of
genes with very tiny effects
and you can put them together in what we
call a poly multiple genic score
to predict
behavior like alcoholism
and so they're not as strong as the
predictors we have for say cognitive
ability
or school performance
but they're getting better all the time
and they're getting better by having
bigger and bigger studies the first
study that was done was called the
welcome trust case control consortium
study in 2007 and they had 2 000 cases
of seven disorders
you know like the the big ones um
uh like
hypercholesterolemia and you know six
other disorders with 2 000 patients and
at the time that was just thought you
know
mammoth samples well now that wouldn't
get published
it's gone to twenty thousand two hundred
thousand and in my area cognitive the
latest study published last month is
based on three million people wow and
the reason for that is if the effects
are so small
that you need huge samples
to detect the effect
i don't know if people will understand
no no no they will if you had a single
gene disorder
you know you only need one family right
to find it
so that's been the um that's been what
we've been up to in the last 10 years
getting bigger and bigger samples where
collaborations among
sometimes hundreds of studies many
hundreds of investigators you know we're
page after page of authors on these
papers but it's kind of cool in a way
that people realize their sample
which they've struggled to collect for
decades
is worthless because it doesn't have the
power to detect these effects so all
they can do
is throw their lot in with everybody
else
but it makes for much better science
really yeah so robert we've talked about
some of the more physical things like
obesity and perhaps addiction people
would argue has a strong physical
component
i want to go to psychology in a second
but first of all what about something as
strongly related to identity as
say sexuality the narrative in society
which is frankly one that i'm sort of
invest not invested in but one i go with
is that you know if you're gay or
straight or bi or whatever it is that's
a hundred percent genetic there is no
environmental influence how true is that
well when this research the first twin
studies and then adoption studies were
done on sexuality 30 years ago or so
that wasn't the prevailing view
i mean it was more that it was a matter
of lifestyle choices and what your
mother how your mother treated you in
the first few years of life so the
research coming out showing that there's
genetic influence on it not not real
high genetic influence moderate genetic
influence
that created quite a storm and then when
someone said they found a gene on the x
chromosome that's related to that which
turns out not to be true
that really um upped the ante a bit so
people were
not you know they were quite hostile to
the idea but the gay community
liked it
because you know it wasn't just a
lifestyle choice and they were making
life difficult for their parents and
other people or whatever so it's
interesting to hear you say that you
think if we did a survey now most people
would think that it's very highly
heritable i have no doubt that most
people would answer that way yeah yeah i
worked at an adolescent treatment center
where we had several boys who were
gay and they
they were almost in the treatment center
because they were gay and they created
such problems in their life this is back
in the 70s
but um their stories were they just knew
from early on right you know
and so i tend to agree with you but
um it's it's a difficult thing to study
because even now i think people aren't
totally open about their sexuality
i think
but anyway the data that exists not
surprisingly suggests there's some
genetic influence but it is not
it's not at all
100 heritable i mean it's a long way
from that but there might be chance
factors involved as well
and you know one way to get at this is
with identical twins because they're
that's what the twin studies about
comparing identical
called monozygotic twins it's the same
fertilized egg
so same sperm and egg combined to create
this embryo and it splits in the first
few days of life so these are
genetically identical individuals if you
sequence them they have the same dna
both individuals so to what extent are
they different
and
for hummus uh for
is can we call we call it homosexuality
yes okay
let's worry about i can't keep up with
terms but um for identical twins they're
only i think about sixty percent
concordant
for asexuality what does that mean
robert concordia the same so if one if
you find one identical twin male who's
gay what are the chances that the other
identical twinner gain is certainly not
a hundred percent wow but then people
say you know well but me
maybe if you grow up with someone who's
a your people uh
confuse you all the time if you're an
identical twin the easiest way to tell
if a twin is identical or not is one
question when you were growing up that
people have trouble telling you apart
because that aggregates a lot of
characteristics height weight hair color
which is all identical for identical
twins so it may be that by having this
identical person around
maybe you forge a separate identity or
something like that but i don't know i
mean there aren't any traits complex
traits that are 100 heritable so it
doesn't surprise me that identical twins
differ i mean they're not always the
same for sexual preference wow that's
really interesting and so moving on to
psychology now which is obviously an
error you focused on heavily in your
work
um
how heritable are things like political
beliefs for example uh cultural
positions you know think things of that
nature yeah views world views if we
describe it that way well people are
surprised if everything's heritable and
people were surprised though to find out
that attitudes
you know are also heritable
now unlike a lot of other
traits in psychology attitudes
especially political attitudes and
religiosity
show some influence of the nurture of
the family in which you're brought up
but they're also substantially heritable
and
[Music]
that still
bothers people i think but you know
there's so many studies not showing that
it's
incontrovertible but it's common sense
isn't it robert like you we hear you all
our lives when we when we're talking
they'll say or you just remind me just
of your grandfather when you do that or
of your mum when you say it that when
you say that thing you're just like your
dad when you do this yeah it's common
sense isn't it really
i mean you could say that's
environmental though couldn't you you
could yeah yeah but what's
impressive with these
identical twins are rarely reared apart
but there's several hundred pairs that
have been found that have been reared
apart there's a famous minnesota study
that brought identical twins who had
been reared apart
until adulthood they bring them together
for the first time and keep them
together for a week and test them on
something like 50 000
bits of information
and um
it's it's amazing when you see them
first come together i mean it's like
mind-boggling or there's a film that won
one of those film awards it's a
documentary film called three identical
strangers so that's a more recent
example of just this identical triplets
sometimes
so identical twins happen when the same
fertilized egg splits in the first few
days of life sometimes one of those will
split again wow and you get identical
triplets it's very rare one in ten
thousands of of twins so it's very rare
but there was a case there was a
adoption agency in new york that in the
50s and and going into the 60s
thought it was difficult to adopt kids
probably wrong but then it was
particularly difficult to adopt twins
so they said well
we'll adopt the kids separately but was
wicked was they didn't tell the adoptive
parents and it was really um
a rogue psychiatrist who thought this
would be the perfect nature nurture
experiment
and because he actually reared them put
adopted them into very different homes
if like in the triplets one went into a
lower class home immigrant parents the
other one in middle class home high
school teacher and the third went into a
home of a lawyer and a surgeon i think
in long island one of the wealthiest
areas so their environments differed as
much as could be but as you see in the
film when these guys get together you
know it's
like they found themselves really i mean
within an hour so they're wrestling on
the floor these 20 year old
males you know they're just
um
they were all into wrestling
[Music]
wrestling you know but they had that
stocky sort of build and they didn't
mind
i find it important you know to be
cuddling with these
it's not cuddling i suppose with these
sweaty men and stuff but they they just
john irving the author was also very
much into wrestling and he talks about
this that same sort of thing that it's
this appetites issue again that you know
you kind of go with what feels right for
you but they all went to wrestling
there's so many examples like that
though they all when they got together
they realized none of them they were all
very smart they read a lot they just
didn't like university so they all
dropped out of university decided
they're kind of entrepreneurial they
started a nightclub called triplets in
manhattan wow and you know because they
love that sort of thing staying up all
night and having a lot of you know they
lived together in a bachelor pad that
was real wild with sex drugs and rock
and roll
while it lasted and
um so it's a great i really recommend
that film the first half of the film
which is what i've just been telling you
about the second half of the film and a
new book that's just come out explores
why were these guys separated and you
know talks about this very wicked story
that was before the days of ethics
permission for things and
um
so that's a very
dark story
and robert
for these twins are the outcomes roughly
the same even though they got placed in
a lower class home middle class home
upper class did they all end up in the
same place or the fact that one kid
ended up getting the best possible
education mean that and connections mean
that they did slightly better or yeah
well that one kid in that very wealthy
family had all the opportunities you're
suggesting but didn't really do much
better at school because he just it just
didn't turn him on i mean he you know he
didn't want to go an academic route
and so they ended up being amazingly
similar in personality
in
education and cognitive abilities which
is my interest in particular but also
psychopathology um one committed suicide
while this film was being made shortly
i guess before the film was made
and you know you say whoa then
the other two didn't but then it turns
out all three of them lived in different
families not knowing the existence of
the others all three of them had therapy
for depression in adolescence which in
the 50s was extremely rare
so
that's that's an example of how one
committed suicide but they were all
depressive and what we know about
suicide is it's often
um
a spontaneous act in a way you know like
there's a bbc documentary on it that i
think is very good about the epidemic of
male depression and there's a lot of
contagion there and
i mean it seems weird that someone could
take their life on a whim in a way but
lots of stories about a guy who
decides he's going to jump off this
bridge but if someone just smiles at him
he says okay i won't
you know so
so the fact that one committed suicide
and the others didn't
doesn't surprise me too much what does
surprise me is the fact that
despite these very different backgrounds
all three were treated for depression in
adolescence
wow
that's
that's so interesting isn't it
it's just an anecdote though isn't it
it's just one case but it is backed up
by other systematic studies of identical
twins reared apart which are very
dramatic
but because their situations their
circumstances are so unusual
to have identical twins adopted a part
that the other methods are actually more
valuable in terms of
basic science like comparing identical
and non-identical twins
although they're all reared together in
a home the fact is they're all born in
the same womb they're all the same age
they're reared in the same home
and there's a big difference though one
group is twice as similar genetically as
the other group identical twins are 100
similar and non-identical twins like any
brother and sister are 50 similar so if
genetics is important you'd have to
predict that the identical twins are
more similar than the non-identical
twins and then the adoption method is
neat because it's completely different
it's taking genetically related people
reared apart or weird together so for
example parents in offspring
are 50 similar genetically but they the
children grow up in the home of those
parents so that's why for a century
psychology has interpreted resemblance
in families as nurture
you know it's not crazy and especially
at a time when no one was thinking about
genetics no one said well but they are
50 similar genetically could it be
genetic they never thought about that
but the adoption method which first
study was done in 49 and i did a very
large study in the 70s in colorado
you take
in in those days uh this was like in
the early well
you know in the united states i won't go
in the whole story but with the swinging
60s there was a lot of illegitimate
bursts because birth control wasn't
really available then and adoption and
abortion wasn't really an option either
so there were a lot of kids being put up
for adoption
and so we studied i studied the birth
mothers who at that time went away from
their home because it was such a
negative thing to have a baby out of
wedlock they'd go into these homes for
unwed mothers for the last trimester
when they were showing and and we tested
them in these homes and then studied the
kids and their adoptive parents as the
kids grew up into their teenage years so
that you've you've taken
parents who share genes and environment
with their kids and we know they're
similar for everything
but we you then almost experimentally
divide the genetics and the environment
you've got nature parents the biological
parents and they're adopted away kids
who in those days
you have to say you'll never see the kid
again you know it's not like today where
birth parents are involved in the
raising of their child and then you've
got the nurture parents the adoptive
parents who adopt these kids and just to
give you one concrete example we were
talking about weight
you know the correlation between parents
and offspring for weight is 0.4 so it's
a correlation is a statistic that goes
from 0 to 1. so 0.4 is a moderate
correlation now parents in offspring are
only 50 similar genetically so from a
genetic point of view you don't expect
it to be much higher than that so anyway
that's point four isn't nature or
nurture well it's always been assumed to
be nurture not in not crazy i mean
parents give the kids their diet and
give them role models for lifestyles of
exercise and all of that
so what about
birth parents and they're adopted away
kids they correlate exactly the same
point four
and then you say but then does that mean
it's all nature and the answer is yes
the correlation between these adoptive
parents who raised the kids from the
first few months of life and their
adopted kid
for weight is zero
there's no correlation
wow so it that's a kind of neat way of
showing that
what runs in families is dna
and tlc is important but it doesn't make
a difference so that particular issue on
that issue but most of the other issues
too but what about something like one of
the things we've explored on this show
for example we've talked to people like
warren farrell who's the author of the
boy crisis and one of the things he
talks about is the impact of
fatherlessness on on boys in particular
but also on girls what happens
statistically speaking and
someone who grows up without a father is
far more likely to end up in prison far
more likely to
misbehave in school and a whole host of
other negative outcomes so how would you
explain that then
well um
if you
i'm trying to think of the shorter
version of this but the
um
you can't assume that environmental
factors are all environment now the
fatherless home is a tougher issue
a tougher example for me to work with
but let me start with another example
one of the
items
that um in in terms of cognitive
development one of the items that is
best predictive of kids cognitive
development is number of books in the
home
and that's always been assumed
to be environmental i mean books don't
have dna so if the number of books in
the home correlates with how well kids
do at school doesn't that have to be
environmental
and it's not it's mostly genetic
and the reason for that is books don't
get on the shelves by themselves who are
the parents who have more books people
with jeans which cause them to have
books in the house pass those g's on to
the kids right now it's a lot harder to
think about that so
most of the environmental measures we
use in psychology life events you know
is
used in i think last count was 5000
studies it's used as an environmental
measure
it shows as much genetic
it's not as heritable as behavioral
traits but on average the environmental
measures we use in psychology are about
25 percent heritable
and life events you know the big items
are things like um
financial disruption getting
in uh conflicts with people losing your
job well that's not the environment out
there independent of us we have
something to do with that environment
and so i think it's very important to
recognize that
just because we give something the name
a label of environment doesn't make it
environmental in fact you're safer
saying there's probably genetic
influence so robert just so that we
don't lose the audience and also don't
lose me because you're very clever and
i'm not i'm struggling to keep up are
you sort of saying that the
fatherlessness is a genetic issue see
that's why i was going to say it's a
harder
one to go to but you have to consider
the possibility that there's genetic
influence on that
in other words and this is going to
sound very sort of blamey and whatever
i'm just trying to get to the truth and
we're not trying to judge anyone or
whatever people have their own
individual circumstances but
what correct me when i say so what
you're saying is
a person who might end up being a single
parent
passes certain genes onto their child
that a person who will less likely end
up as a single parent passes on to their
child and therefore the life outcomes
are different is that what you're saying
um yeah basically okay but i mean you
have to consider that possibility it's
it's a hard thing to study but a thing
that has been studied is divorce which
is part of this sure now um
fatherless homes are a bigger issue than
divorce yes but if you take divorce
divorce is related to lots of problems
in kids
right yes
and
people say well
clearly that's an environmental factor
right i mean most most people assume
they don't even think about the
possibility there could be genetic
influence several studies now show like
everything there's heritable influence
on divorce
wow and when you ask well where does
that come from
it's it's a better example because it
may be positive
the the sort of people like me i can
talk about this because i've been
married three times
so
um
people who get divorced uh this is on
average they tend to be kind of
risk-taking
joel de vivre things that probably make
them attractive initially but probably
make them less
safe bets for long-term relationships
right because the joie de vivre kind of
goes away after a few years you know so
[Laughter]
there's a conference for my current yeah
yeah current life is perfect i see so
well that actually makes sense sorry
francis i just want
divorced the voice doesn't happen to you
i mean
that's your life that's your
relationship right
you manifest it in the world
you know what this is the thing that is
really great about having on the show is
like i haven't thought about these
things nearly carefully enough and
therefore i'm going with a lot of like
narratives that i haven't actually
examined so it's fascinating to have
this but really good to talk about it as
a new parent and um
i think uh
i was going to write a follow-up book to
blueprint because the four pages in the
book about parenting have gotten more
attention than anything else
and i don't know if you've looked around
at parenting books but you know there
are literally um thousands of parenting
books
hardly any of them even mention genetics
whereas i think the most important thing
for parents to know
is that they have less control than they
think they do
because genetics is a very you know it's
the most important systematic source of
differences the environment's important
but the environment that makes a
difference isn't really systematic
that means you as a parent you know so i
think it's really important for parents
to understand that message so it'd be
kind of fun to
think about whether this has an impact
on you know you and i do you have you
thought about these issues at all no
because the way i think about it i
suppose is i've always seen it as my job
as a parent and maybe look i'm three
weeks into it what the hell do i know
but the way i see it is about
observing what my child's
aptitudes and appetites are and
facilitating them
in that journey so i don't want my child
to be a lawyer or a basketball player i
do want them to be a basketball player
but
like a a thing that i've decided for
them
but what i hope to be able to do is to
pay attention enough that i can see this
again and give them opportunity enough
that they can find exactly right what
they're good at and what they're
interested in and then facilitate that
journey as best i can as a parent that's
that's the way i've always looked at it
well and that was the message i had in
those four pages in blueprint but um
a lot of parents don't want to hear they
don't have control but
one percent of the population gets
diagnosed as schizophrenic
and
you don't as a parent you don't find out
about that until late adolescence early
adulthood so things are going along well
and then suddenly you know this train
truck hits you um
and
uh if you think you're totally
responsible for everything that happens
to your kid that is a tough devastation
tough thing to swallow yeah and so
um
and i do get a lot of letters from
people who
say
you know everything seems to be going
well but then in adolescence the kids
hit drugs and other peers and stuff and
you know they're blaming themselves for
this but you know that's that's one of
those sort of idiosyncratic things that
you just don't have control about you
hope if you make things
good enough and stable enough for your
kid i think in some ways you got to
write off adolescence i worked at an
adolescent treatment center for three
years and you know kids parents doing
well before and and then things just
fall apart and in this case they were in
the judicial system these kids and put
into these homes but then afterwards
most of the time they stabilize and
sometimes i think you know if we could
put kids away on some south sea island
and have them come back you know so
there's hope for parents but there's a
lot of parents who sign up for that
with teenage kids well in england they
do don't they they send into boarding
schools
that is how we deal with it indeed
hey francis do you like books i tried
one once wasn't for me mike not enough
pictures of fit brand birds never
working with you again but if you like
fantasy check out the ripples in reality
series by j.s pal they're absolutely
brilliant and they have a five gold star
rating on amazon i've heard of them
they're beautifully written and
completely original if you want a book
that allows you to delve into different
worlds and helps you escape the insanity
of real life then ripples in reality is
for you
see i know the word delve so i do read
books amazing just imagine books written
in the style of game of thrones lord of
the rings forgotten realms with an added
pinch of stargate it's catnip for people
like me virgins
she started a publishing company named
poppy field publishing and her novels
are a massive hit with fans who want to
read books that are a great read and are
not woke book one is shadow step
and book two gather shadows
she's currently writing book number
three i can't wait i don't read books
because i can talk to girls your mum
doesn't count mate and by the way js
powell is a big supporter of
trigonometry she is a moderator on our
channel and we really appreciate all her
help you can find her books online at
amazonlulu.com and other bookseller
websites if you enjoy the books please
leave a review the links are in the
description
[Music]
but robert we've been talking about
things like mental illness and obesity
and you know these are very important
topics but they have a slight negative
edge so let's look at something more
positive which is talents
things like musicality or particular
gift in sport or art are those heritable
everything's heritable but it's harder
to study the extremes
so you know if you're talking about
super athletes yes there's just a few of
them in the world but there's a huge
interest in that in terms of athletics
with the dna revolution because if you
can predict it's like with race horses
they're really keen on the genetics
because if you can predict the tiniest
little edge
that could be the difference between a
winner and a loser so there's a lot of
interest
in making those predictions genetically
but the
the data
as they exist suggest that the extremes
of any of these distributions like in
cognitive ability or
sports to the extent it's been studied
there's a little bit on musicality now
but the idea the the extremes are not
ideologically different
from the rest of the distribution
so
do you know what i mean that no people
used to think well
geniuses you know really gifted people
tops athletics they're they're just a
different species you know there's some
weird some unusual gene that they have
or something like that it's not the case
i mean within the range that we can
study which as i say is not the one in a
million but we're probably getting into
the one in ten thousand sort of area
which in athletics might be
regional champions you know but they're
not going to be olympic stars at that
level but at that level of individual
differences the genetics is the same and
so when we get these polygenic scores
there's no break point it's just a
normal distribution so the more of these
positive genes that you have of which
there are thousands that affect any of
these traits the higher you'll be the
the propensity is there it doesn't make
you be a super athlete or not so i think
that's really interesting and the other
end of it is important too
that this genetics work is kind of like
the nail in the coffin for diagnostic
approaches
where the medical model has made us
think
that
the most important thing is to diagnose
something properly
and that's true if like in england the
first case of you know cholera what
causes cholera and then
to say what is the cause of cholera well
you want to start by making sure you
know who has cholera and a lot of people
have tummy problems but you know with
cholera you're talking about something
more serious so you diagnose it then you
find the cause and it turns out it's
contaminated drinking water so that's
the medical model of a disorder and you
know if you have a single
influence
it could be a single gene influence as
well you want to diagnose it carefully
and it's dichotomous this all started
with mendel you know if you think of his
seven p plant traits that he studied
they were dichotomous you either have
wrinkled seeds or smooth seeds and
that's a single gene causing it
but for common disorders as well as
behavioral traits it's not like that
there are thousands of tiny effects and
that makes it all probabilistic and not
deterministic you know there are
thousands seven thousand ten thousand
single gene
disorders in humans where a single gene
causes a disorder
necessary and sufficient for the
development of the disorder
so
those are dichotomous you know necessary
and sufficient you only get um
huntington's disease if you have this
mutation on the tip of chromosome 4.
and it and
conversely if you have that
mutation you will get huntington's and
you know you'll you'll die from
huntington's regardless of how much you
exercise or whatever it's a single gene
disorder and that's in a way a problem
for us that's the way people think about
genetics you say genetics and for a long
time we had to fight in media that you'd
have a story in the paper about it and
the headline writer who's always
different from the guy who writes the
story would always say the gene four you
know no it's not a gene we're talking
about for complex medical disorders the
vast majority maybe 95 of the medical
burden is not caused by these single
gene disorders because they're very rare
because natural selection
gets rid of them if they're have
reproductive
repercussions
so we're talking about these common
disorders and yet psychiatry has been
held back by the medical model
where you say
are you schizophrenic or not
are you depressed or not are you
alcoholic or not but if you know people
who are alcoholic depressed
schizophrenic you know it's not an
either or thing you don't wake up one
day and you're alcoholic it's a long
slow process and some people function a
lot better with you know at very high
levels of alcohol than other people so
it's really a quantitative thing not
qualitative and that has a lot of
implications but
there's a strong sense in psychiatry now
that we've done a disservice to people
by pretending that we can diagnose these
things precisely so that the mother
whose kid has trouble reading can say
oh i've just found out from the doctor
my child has dyslexia
it doesn't mean anything
it really doesn't mean it just means
they have reading problems but by giving
it a medical diagnosis and especially
you give it a greek or latin name that
makes it sound really medical you don't
call it
hyperactivity you call it hyperactivity
attention deficit disorder or math isn't
called kid has problem with math it's
this calculia yeah you know to make it
sound more medical but it really does a
disservice to pretend that there's those
people who are schizophrenic and us
normals
and
the polygenic scores really show that we
all have
thousands of risk fact tiny genetic risk
factors for say schizophrenia in fact my
polygenic score for schizophrenia is
quite high it's maybe at the 85th
percentile oh wow
but only one percent of the population
gets diagnosed to schizophrenic so it's
a long way from 99
but still 85 seems high and what's cool
about that is there's three studies now
that say well let's look at these people
throughout the distribution and what if
you have
a high polygenic score
it turns out people from creative
professions have higher polygenic scores
for schizophrenia oh we could have told
you that from our comedy industry
experience not that they're
schizophrenics perhaps it's that they
think outside the box yeah you know and
maybe maybe if you start thinking too
far outside the house yeah you go off
the deep end yeah yeah yeah i remember
watching this program since we're
talking about single genes and maybe you
can disabuse me of this is i watched
this program on the bbc where they said
uh psychopathy could be
tracked down in particular to one gene
they called it the warrior gene
is is that true that if you have this
particular gene you're more you're far
less likely to be empathetic
far less likely to be caring of your
fellow human being and more focused on
your on your own needs yeah no it's
totally wrong i mean
there was a phase in the 90s when people
when scientists were first able to
genotype these genes and they would
focus on a few neurotransmitter genes i
think that's the mao monoamine oxidase
a or b
[Laughter]
and so there was a phase there where
people were
because it was very expensive to
genotype yeah and they they couldn't
afford to genotype large samples so
um they found uh there were several
studies that reported the so-called
warrior gene but
um
since then in the late 90s people
realize these things aren't replicating
and the reason is that this is genetics
contribution to the replication crisis i
don't know if you guys have gotten into
this at all but yes you know so many
major findings don't replicate well that
was genetics contribution to the
replication crisis because they did
everything wrong the samples were too
small they only could have detected
large effects and they only published
stuff when they got the result that they
expected to find worse yet they analyzed
things a bunch of different ways to show
the one that reached this magical
statistical significance level of 0.05
it's all crazy nonsense stuff that you
know the replication crisis has tried to
solve being really neat you should get
some guys like my colleague stuart
richie wrote a book called the
great title science fictions about the
replication crisis that came out last
year
it's a such an important issue from a
science point of view and i think from
the public to realize that a lot of
these classic findings not just in
psychology but worse in in pharmacology
drug studies medical studies as well
you know they
they they're not doing science right i
mean they're not they're not it's not um
fraud
it's more a matter of you know you just
there's lots of ways to analyze stuff
and they're they're they're doing
everything to increase
the probability of getting this result
in which case statistics is out the
window so it's not fraud but the
outcomes are fraudulent or they're wrong
anyway yeah yeah but you know science is
self-correcting so that's cool i mean
you know that we are able now to say a
lot of these findings you see in
textbooks are wrong yeah
that's fascinating robert we could talk
for hours and hours and hours uh but
before we we head towards the end of the
interview one of the things i wanted to
talk about is the future
what is genetics going to help us do
and what are we
going to be able to achieve as a result
of the research you've been doing and
your colleagues are doing in terms of
medical practices
social policy cultural attitudes all of
these parenting all of these areas of
our lives
what does the future hold for us and
what are some of the benefits of genetic
research right well i'm glad you asked
that because the first 30 years of my
career were basically just showing
people genetics is important
and that has some implications you know
like in education for example to
recognize the kids are different i would
have been happy if my career ended with
that i mean that was really quite a
radical transformation of psychology but
then the dna revolution came along with
the ability to sequence the human genome
to find the millions of dna differences
between us to use them to be able to
predict
genetic influence
and so
um the future is here now i mean there's
80 million pound pilot project with the
nhs to do the dna testing
and in areas like cardiovascular disease
which everything is heritable that's a
little more heritable than most things
if you the neat thing about dna is you
can predict from birth
and if you can predict you can prevent
and so all of medicine is moving away
from the model or you wait till some
someone has a heart attack
and it's it's said that a severe heart
attack cost the nhs 700 000 pounds not
counting
the loss of quality of life you know all
in
on it
so if you could predict and prevent a
heart attack from occurring
you know it's just a no-brainer so all
of medicine is moved towards this
prevention sort of model and dna is the
best early warning system in town we
know interventions for everything work
better earlier than they do later and
we're not that good at fixing things i
mean we can
you know patch up your heart but you
still had a massive heart attack and
your heart isn't going to be the way it
was before that so that's where it's
it's happening and the neat thing is you
just get
it costs about real cost about 40 quid
to do this dna testing it's the cheapest
thing you can do and yet that one
where you you get
um it's called a snip chip size of
postage stamp and it can genotype say
600 000 dna markers throughout the whole
genome that's what we're basically
talking about it's now moving towards
whole genome sequencing where you get
all three billion base pairs of dna
which is the end of the story that's all
you inherit but but you can do a lot
with these snip chips and that's what
the nhs is currently
piloting some countries like finland and
estonia
already make this a routine part of
medical care if you go into a hospital
you're asked would you like us
to do these polygenic score predictors
we're only going to tell you if it's
something you can do something about and
you know with heart risk i mean i'm in
this category of you know reasonably
high cardiovascular risk
which is the dna is a lot better
information than just my family because
i don't think anyone had a particular
heart problem in my family but i do and
the cholesterol and stuff blood pressure
corresponds to that
so if i know that then
i might just pay more attention to the
stuff you hear that we're all supposed
to do eat better exercise more lose
weight which is a factor in all these
things um so
you know it just seems to be a
no-brainer that we want to go that way
and
so it'll happen first in medicine it's
happening already
but
people aren't waiting for that 25
million people have paid about a hundred
quid to have a direct-to-consumer
company test their dna using the same
approach
and so dozens of these companies have
sprung up to
provide information about athletics
cosmetics i didn't know that that was a
huge area a lot of you know that
women might prefer some cosmetics based
on their genetics i guess some cosmetics
are more dangerous i don't know but then
also diet
and now
a bit scary is um
the the um go-to shower gift in
southeast asia is dna testing for kids
parents who want
uh advice on the genetic
uh strengths and weaknesses of their
children and these companies provide
parenting information it's all i'm kind
of doing an expose on that now because i
think
the results aren't there yet you can
tell a little bit
but but you know you you can make a
pretty good prediction about your kid's
height for example
and even though he's going to be about
five foot eight i promise you i don't
know six to eight probably yeah
but
and so it's kind of fun to find out
about some of these things but it can
also
go over the top and
the the weird thing is completely
unregulated there's absolutely no
regulation we could just set up a
company today start getting dna from
people advise them on being comedians or
whatever
you know so that's it's all kind of
wicked and then the parenting
information they give people
is not is is not based on any science
really right so they need to be reined
in a bit but it shows you that there's a
tremendous interest
in people willing to pay to have this
information themselves i should say that
a lot of the people who are paying of
the 25 million or so it's to get
ancestry data yeah but the same dna
chip gives you all this other stuff as
well right so they get that too
because
i think this is undoubtedly going to be
an error based on my very layman
understanding in which
uh there's a lot of progress made in
terms of helping people deal with
disease and and prevent disease and so
on but i always sort of there's a
hesitation in the back of my mind if i'm
honest with you robert where
i worry that we're at some point going
to get to a minority report sort of
situation where it's like oh you have a
nine you're in the 96 percentile for
committing violent crime
off to the prison you go type of
situation is that is that something we
should be you know extra careful about
when we're exploring these issues yeah
well people usually bring up the movie
the 1996 movie gattaca along those lines
because that's probably more relevant
because that was gattaca g a t's and c's
are the four nucleotide letters in the
dna alphabet and so that's all about
this as well as 1984 was you know really
all these utopias have a view on this
sort of thing
um but i know what you mean with
minority report if they had these
polygenic scores and minority report was
silly with the neural sort of thing but
you're absolutely right you could
substitute dna there but if you did
you'd know that you never have 100
prediction
so that's a big difference you know it's
only a propensity and even that
propensity is not deterministic i mean i
think a good example is alcoholism we
can't predict too much now but we can
make some prediction i know what it is
four or five percent of the variance
and if you knew you were at risk for
alcoholism you would also know you
cannot become alcoholic if you don't
drink alcohol a lot of alcohol over a
lot of time it's not like you drink one
drink in your alcoholic
so if your kid had a high risk for
alcoholism even though it's not very
predictive you might just me he is
russian gene so yeah he's 100 i was
thinking that way
and you could say
well we all hear the advice you know
drink sensibly take holidays from it to
see how much you're dependent on it
but if you knew you had the genetic risk
it's such a low-tech low-cost
intervention to say maybe you'll pay
more attention to it so when your son
reaches adolescence you say you know it
doesn't mean you're going to become
alcoholic even if you have a high
polygenic score for alcoholism but maybe
you're a little bit more at risk than
your friends so when they all get
bombed out of their minds you might want
to stop and say well is that really
worth it is it worth taking that risk
you know so i think you can do these
things with a body weight cardiovascular
alcoholism you can do it at a low tech
level and then maybe eventually we'll go
to higher tech approaches to it but um i
can i so i'm what i'm saying is i'm a
cheerleader for this stuff because
there's so many people who worry about
so much of this you know not not just
the concern you have but
um data
you know
stealing data and you know
big data finding out everything about us
you know so there are a lot of things to
be concerned about but
for me the positives just so outweigh
the negatives and
i don't know why everybody focuses on
the negatives we need some people like
me saying but wait a minute there's some
incredibly positive things here like
wouldn't you want to know that what is
it something like five percent of the
male population is like at a
uh is it a
five six-fold greater risk of having a
severe heart attack based on this
genetic information
wouldn't you want to know that it just
seems to me like such a non-brainer when
i give a public lecture and i talk about
like alzheimer's for example if you do
23andme which is the most popular of
these direct-to-consumer companies
one of the things you find out about is
your risk for alcoholism now there's
just a couple of genes there that make a
big difference but it goes from having a
say 10 15 percent risk of
alzheimer's at 80 85 in late in life
from 10 15 percent to 60 some percent
that's not 100 but as medical risks go
that's astronomical
and so if you do 23 and me
they finally made you have a triple lock
on it you had to say yes i want to know
about it and then yes i read this stuff
you gave me a link for and yes i won't
hold you responsible but then you find
out if you're in the unlucky one percent
of the population that has this 60 full
percent risk and you can find that out
for your kid i mean so you can find it
out very early in life so i ask a public
audience would you want to know and it's
interesting it splits right down the
middle half of the people say you know
definitely not there's nothing you can
do about it but the other half like me
says yeah knowledge is power i want to
know
and
i mean for me you can do something about
it maybe you can't do anything medically
about it but if you knew that you were
at this very substantial risk for having
alzheimer's when you got older you'd
arrange social care you try to set
yourself up economically and
and um importantly i think a little bit
more carpe diem you know where people
say i'm not going to spend my whole life
so that i set myself up when i'm in my
80s
um you know i'm going to live life now a
bit more
so i think there are things you can do
about it but it is interesting how
people split down the middle on that
it is it is
robert it's been fascinating we must
have you back i'd love to come back
speak about your kid and how he's
developing well and perhaps you'll write
the parenting book that i can use i
started but i just can't write like that
to write a parenting book you really
have to write you have to get down with
the people and my book i thought
blueprint i thought was very low level i
had to hold my nose on some of the stuff
talking you know they want you to talk
about yourself and your life and talk
about a sailing trip across and with the
kids you know um the parenting books god
they're so
low-level and condescending i just can't
i just can't do it you know so well
we'll bring you back and talk about it
at least okay i'd love to do that yeah
but our final question is always the
same what is the one thing we're not
talking about
that we really should be
um well we have talked about parenting
which is important i think the dna
revolution hasn't quite sunk in like i
don't know how many people know there's
this 80 million pound trial in the nhs
for this and so the reason i wrote the
book blueprint is i wanted to give
people the the literacy they need to
discuss these
important issues this isn't like a lot
of medical things you know if you've
ever noticed you hear of a discovery and
they say in 10 years this is going to be
big that means they have no idea if it's
going to happen if they say five years
it means maybe it'll happen but the
point about this is it's happening now
and this is really transformational so i
think people need to know about it and i
just hope we can have podcasts like
yours where you teach people how to
discuss these firmly held views as
adults and just say these aren't simple
issues you know there's there are things
to discuss but can't we just discuss
them reasonably
yeah not at the moment you would see but
uh we are trying and you're trying
robert it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much the book is of course
blueprint i really recommend everybody
gets it we're going to ask you a couple
of questions from our supporters for our
supporters but for now thank you so much
for your time absolutely pleasure and
thank you for watching and listening we
will see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or raw
show all of them go out at 7 pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
is it theoretically possible that the
genetic component of intelligence could
be edited pre or post-conception